tourism are at the dress rehearsal the
evening before the festival of lights
opens it's only when the slides are
projected onto the building that the
artist knows if all the months of work
have paid off wows if the side looks
great it's there for the first time and
it's totally new for me a big surprise
ma has completed eight light collages
for the pallium festoons grabbin in
central Berlin she wants her work called
prisma to change the perception of the
building the substance of my work begins
with white light when it falls on
raindrops you have a rainbow it makes
you want to look twice and that's how it
is with this building you know this
projection will certainly make Berliners
look at it closely so on shawna p.m.
friday Felina kanawa him
tourism our works intuitively she says
her images fit together like a puzzle
first she creates a collage from 200 to
300 paper snippets that she's cut out of
magazines the finished image is scanned
she then edits and processes it on her
computer till she's satisfied Teresa ma
says she is a painter who uses different
ways to present her art a canvas
involves public spaces and buildings
which he paints in bright colors I most
often by own talent you obviously have
to have a talent and drive in
implementing things without it you can't
have a profession like this vision
forged and I can imagine how an image
can appear in a larger dimension ma
presented her first work in Vienna in
2006 her international breakthrough came
at the glow lights festival in the
Netherlands in 2010 a year later she
brightened up Berlin Cathedral at the
festival of lights in 2012 her
installation sinfonia lit up the concert
house at Berlin's Jean darman marked
this year her images can be seen on two
buildings together with other artists de
rosamma has once again illuminated
Berlin Cathedral in Berlin Berlin has
huge buildings and strolling squares
this city has a feel for space it's
perfect for a light projection does it's
perfect for Annalise boys on the
festival of lights is to brighten the
German capital for 12 nights famous
artworks give a new look to potsdamer
platz
the Brandenburg Gate has huge
three-dimensional images known as video
mappings and the facade of the Hotel de
Rome boasts some old masters the lights
festival has already become a tourist
magnet organizers expect around 2
million visitors sure enough gorgeous
colors that's amazing it changes the
building's character and makes it more
cheerful looks very spectacular now
rainbow colors everywhere I simply like
it when you see so many lights and
colors in the night you don't notice
that it's cold and windy in that it's
autumn helps this these light images are
like snapshots but arrays amides part of
her concept she wants viewers to reflect
for a moment and keep the image in their
memories Nexus come to the next thing is
I'll be illuminating the armitage in
Amsterdam that's a 100 meter long facade
and i'll be using a moving image and
then we'll see if I'm back in Berlin
next year and otherwise there are a few
buildings in the world that fascinate me
and draw me and that i would like to
illuminate someday and his those below
that i wish to one of her dreams is to
light up the philharmonic in luxembourg
and to bring art to the streets there to
the festival of lights does add a splash
of color to Berlin's autumn nights
you